FIRST WITH MOTTE SENDING THE
PUCK IN FROM CENTRE.
DRIEDGER OUT FOR AN EARLY TO
EXCITEMENT.
LAMMIKKO RIGHT AWAYD THE PUCK T
>> John G.: THE GOALTENDERS, YOU
AFTER TYLER MOTTE HAD OPENED THE
SCORING.
McCANN'S'S BACK TOWARDS GIORDAN.
WENNBERG...
HE PL I FELT ABOUT
BLACKJACK THE FIRST COUPLE TIME
ON THE ORIGINAL TEAMS, HOW ABOUT
MARK GI THERE FOR
HUNT!
NOW AGARLAND.
HE SWEEPS ONE BACK BEHIND.
TYLER MOTTE BACK IN DEEP.
LAMMIKKO BEHIND THET, BUT HERE..
TYLER MOTTE KNOCKS THAT ONE DOWN
AS THE KRAKENOPINION.
>> John S.: YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
IT FROM
BLOCKED BY LAUZON.
WORKS HIS WAY IN.
8 1/INCE JANUARY 1st IN
SEATTLE, AND THE CANUCKS HAVE A
NOW ANOTHER SHOT, THEY SCORE!
BO HORVAT!
[ HoTED
THIS, SHORTY WAS THAT LONG WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ICING PASS.
HERE'S THE PETTERSSON SHOT OVER
DRIEDGER'S SHOULDER.
THAT ALL STARTED WITH THAT LONG
CENTRE.
HOGLANDER ABLE TO FREE I JUHO LO
IT TO BO HORVAT.
HERE'S WINS THE FACEOFF.
GIORDANO SETS IT UP. STARTED
THE PENALTY KILL.
35 SECONDS GONE IN THE HIGHMORE
MINOR. SHOT, HIT
THE POST!
BREAK WHEN THAT CLEARING PLAY BY
TYLER MYERS HIT THE REFEREE.